[Music]
foreign
Hunt is a self-described public health
activist and Community organizer whose
failed Congressional bid made the news
due to the fact that she was using only
fans to raise money for her campaign now
In fairness to her lots of politicians
are prostitutes so she was just being
more honest about it you might say
before running for congress hunt was for
a brief period a stripper and again you
could argue that that was relevant
career experience for an aspiring DC
politician but now that her political
dreams have been put on hold hunt has
been able to get back to her Public
Health activism and that's what she was
apparently trying to do presumably with
a recent viral tweet thread in which she
tries to raise the alarm that not enough
people are having sex she tweeted this
quote young men aren't having sex
exclamation point nearly a third of men
under 30 have not had sex and a higher
percent do not have as much sex as
they'd like not exactly surprising but
this kind of statistic is a sign of much
deeper problems now she then provides a
chart from The Washington Post which
shows that 28 of men under 30
haven't had sex in the past year not
that there are virgins necessarily as
hunt seems to claim yet even still it is
indicative of a real problem
the question is whether she will
interpret the problem correctly and
offer helpful Solutions
and if we know anything about the left
we know that there really isn't a
question here at all the answer on both
counts is obviously no
so she continues
our society criminalizes sex and sweeps
it under the rug the consequences are
straightforward there's more violence
since platforms like Craigslist were
banned from advertising sex serious
violent crimes against all women not
just sex workers has increased by nearly
a fifth
a man who uh and men who do not have sex
suffer they're less likely to be a part
of the labor force they're more likely
to experience depression nihilism other
mental health issues the metoo movement
accomplished so much and we have to take
the next step normalizing having healthy
positive consensual sex
decriminalizing sex work funding sets
education and creating Outreach programs
that help young people develop healthy
sexual habits we should be moving toward
a right to sex people should be able to
have sex when they feel they want to and
we need to develop services that meet
people's needs without attaching the
baggage of shame or criminalization so
let's talk about sex we need to bring
these discussions to the spotlight
normalizing healthy positive sex will
have too many Downstream benefits to
list we need to move past our history of
Shame it's time to bring sex into the
light
okay
well this is just a mess the train has
gone careening catastrophically off the
rails and that's all the more
frustrating because in this case for
once the train was actually initially on
the rails at least partially at first
she identified a real problem part of a
real problem but that's where in her
insights ended
they ended because to summarize
she located a problem caused by the
sexual Revolution
it then sought to fix it
with Solutions given to her by the
sexual Revolution
she's trying to put out the Flames by
smothering it with dry kindling in other
words so let's go through this more
thoroughly because it is an important
issue
um but but what is the issue exactly yes
large numbers of younger men and women
aren't having sex more to the point
however they're not in romantic
relationships they're they're not
married
the numbers show that the average age of
marriage is getting pushed back
precipitously more and more each year
and as this is happening more and more
men and again women too are dropping out
of the dating pool entirely all but
giving up waving the White Flag so the
lack lack of sex is one significant
feature of the actual underlying concern
which is that people are increasingly
giving up on meaningful romantic
relationships with other flesh and blood
human beings hunt doesn't seem worried
about the human relationship part she
thinks that as long as we can you know
have sex with each other again uh
everything will be fine if everyone
could just go out there and and have sex
everything's fine
doesn't matter who they're having sex
with or in what context all that matters
is the sex she thinks
we could even have government issued
prostitutes or else we could give a
sex-starved Americans an EBT style
credit card that they can go and use at
the local tax-funded whorehouse
like any other Progressive
hunt has decided that everything comes
down to sex and the solution as always
is just more and more sex she believes
that somehow our society is not open
enough about the subject we need to talk
about it more we need to stop sweeping
it under the rug as she phrases it but
this can't possibly be the problem
because there has never been a more sex
saturated culture than ours
everybody with an internet connection or
a smartphone including children can
access at lightning speed literally
billions of hours of pornography
whenever they want and even if they
don't want to access it pornography will
be put in front of their faces
everywhere sex is everywhere it's talked
about everywhere
they put porn in grade school libraries
gay bars host drag queen strip shows for
children as a culture we need more
exposure to sex in the same way that a
guy on his third plate of the Chinese
buffet needs another serving of food
the problem is not in the lack of sexual
exposure
but rather mourn its over abundance and
also in the type of sexual exposure
we're talking about
hunt says that
um we need all this sexual stuff and and
need a lot more of it because we all
have a right to sex
now that's clearly ridiculous so I'm not
going to spend a lot of time chopping
down that particular tree nobody has a
right to sex because if you have a right
to something but if you have a right to
something
that a person who withholds that thing
from you
has infringed on your rights so the
implication then would obviously be that
if a person uh who who doesn't have sex
with you has committed a moral crime
against you that's the implication
like they don't have a right to not have
sex with you if Hunt's idea is correct
and this becomes a justification for
rape and all manner of other atrocities
that may not be what she directly
intends but that is the consequence of
turning sex into a human right
which which it is not
so her Insight on this subject is
obviously quite limited to put it
generously
uh what then are the actual causes of
the problem
well here are a few we're thinking about
first as mentioned uh pornography
okay there's been plenty of research
done on this actual credible research
which consistently shows that people who
regularly view pornography become less
interested in romantic relationships
this applies also to people actually in
romantic relationships which is part of
the reason why pornography usage is tied
to higher rates of divorce
porn along with being morally degenerate
and spiritually corrosive is a source of
kind of empty calories it satiates the
human desire for companionship and
romance
except that it does so in the most
superficial sort of way
a man who is hungry for food might fill
up by you know eating chips and drinking
soda but he's not actually being
nourished
and in a similar way a man who is
desperate for the company of a woman
might get his fill with pornography but
he's not actually satisfying that deep
longing of his heart
he's numbing himself so that he doesn't
feel it as much at least in the moment
second hunt gives credit to the metoo
movement but of course the metoo
movement is a major source of the
problem
a man who would otherwise be inclined to
go out and pursue a woman is now
terrified that he'll trip over any of
the countless land mines that are buried
all over the dating scene
he's worried that even if he tries to
approach a woman pay her a compliment
flirt with her ask her out Etc he'll
find himself accused of sexual
harassment or worse
and third
what lies at the root of all of this
is demoralization
a lack of purpose a lack of meaning
despair
hunt mentions nihilism but she thinks
that nihilism is caused by
or a side effect of the lack of sexual
relationships but it goes the other way
around
a man doesn't give up on female
companionship and then become a nihilist
he becomes a nihilist and then gives up
on female companionship
she is pointing to an issue that is much
farther Downstream
the problem is not simply that men
aren't having sex but that they aren't
getting married to begin with
and the problem is not simply that they
aren't getting married but that they
struggle to see the purpose or meaning
in marriage
or in anything else
and the problem is not simply that men
don't have purpose in their lives but
that we live in a culture that breeds
purpose purposelessness and despair
the culture has signposts all along the
road pointing in a certain direction and
if you follow those signs and you walk
down that way it will lead you directly
off a cliff
where you'll wind up in a moral and
spiritual free fall all the way down
into a cold dark abyss
Alexandra hunt as a leftist is one of
the people who's you know putting those
signs up
directing people into the pit
and as they fall into it she stands
around the edge shouting hey what's the
matter why are you so upset
and that is why she is today
finally canceled and that'll do it for
this portion of the show as we move over
to the members block portion hope to see
you there if not talk to you tomorrow
Godspeed
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]